All right, it is time for Drew's News,
your daily trip to the good news soft-serve machine.
(air whooshing)
Ooh, yum.
I know.
And with me at the desk
is my little sugar cone, Ross Mathews.
Ooh, serve me up a double scoop.
(audience clapping)
Hi, everybody, hi.
I used to work at McDonald's.
I was triple threat, drive-through, register and grill,
and I knew how to do the little flip of the wrist
so it would get that perfect little curl at the top.
I know.
You are the perfect little curl.
(Ross and Drew laughing hysterically)
Thank you for noticing.
I pick up what you're putting down.
Well, we're gonna start with an icon of the silver screen.
She's got a permanent spot
in the Hall of Fame of our hearts.
Jamie Lee Curtis.
Love.
She has a wild new movie out.
(audience cheering)
With the amazing actress and action star Michelle Yeoh,
called "Everything Everywhere All at Once."
And it's a big ball of sci-fi, action, comedy, drama,
I guess every tone in the book.
And "Glamour" reports that Jamie told the directors
from the start that she didn't want to conceal a darn thing
when it came to her body.
Here she is as Deirdre Beaubeirdra, an IRS auditor.
Jamie said, "I've been sucking in my stomach since I was 11,
and I specifically decided to relinquish and release
every muscle that I used to clench and hide the reality."
Yes!
(audience cheering)
Please!
I love her.
I mean, who loves Jamie Lee Curtis?
Hello, hello!
(audience cheering)
And you think about,
she has kept it so real for so long now.
You know what I mean?
She's always managed to be gorgeous,
and hilarious, and talented, and dramatic and all of it.
And she did it in a way that was classy.
And now I love that she is just embracing
exactly who she is and bringing that to her artistry.
Yeah, but do you remember like the movie "Perfect"
with John Travolta?
She's like the workout instructor.
Uh-huh, yeah, of course.
(audience cheering)
She did have like,
I mean, the movie was called like "Perfect"
with a picture of her body.
So but what do you do when your body is on a poster
that says "Perfect"?
Exactly.
And then you're what, supposed to live up
to that for the rest of your life?
Well, like and even in "True Lies,"
remember she's in that little black dress
that's like so tiny?
(audience clapping)
All right, next up, we have an incredible story
and you actually found this story and it just blew me away.
You know, it really shows the human family
coming together in the toughest of times.
"People" reports a group of clowns from Israel
traveled to Moldova to bring some joy and laughter
to Ukrainian children
crossing the border with their families.
The clowns are from the Dream Doctors Project.
It's a group of professional medical clowns.
I didn't know there were medical clowns, but there are.
And they provide laughter and therapy to medical patients,
veterans and Holocaust survivors back home.
And the clowns say they might not speak Ukrainian,
but humor is universal.
And that is so true.
(audience cheering)
Ross, I love this story so much.
It's my favorite story.
I love it, I love it, I love it.
I'm so glad we got to report on it.
No words that I could ever say
could match up to the majesty of them.
Thank you for doing what you're doing.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Ah.
Agreed.
(upbeat music)